- [Instructor] When we think
of the term extinction,
we tend to think of
events like what happened,
what we believe happened
63 million years ago
when a large meteor hit the earth
and killed most of the dinosaurs.
And I say most of them,
because a lot of animals
that we know today
especially birds, birds like chickens,
we believe are actually descended
from some of the dinosaurs that survived.
And other species not just dinosaurs
would have gone extinct,
but clearly some other
species did survive.
Our ancestors might've been
some type of burrowing
squirrel rodent like thing
that maybe was under the ground
and was able to survive
the immediate shocks
and then somehow find food
even when the earth was covered by dust
and there wasn't a lot of
photosynthesis going on,
but they were able to survive somehow.
What we're gonna do in this
video though is think about
more subtle notion of extinction.
It's not always caused
by these massive changes
in the environment.
But one thread,
one theme that we will be
talking about in extinction
is that the environment is to
some degree always changing.
And when there is
variation in a population,
so I'm gonna draw some variation as I do
with the different colored circles.
If the environment changes gradually
or in certain slow ways,
there will oftentimes be variants,
members of the population
that will be more likely
to succeed than others.
And so those variants
that are more suitable
for those changes in the environment,
well, they will reproduce
more, they will survive more.
They will become the dominant variant
and over time they can
even become a new species.
And so over time you have
species won't go extinct,
but they would be adapting
or maybe even evolving
into other species that are
more suited to the environment.
But our meteorite dinosaur example
shows us that change is
not always a gradual.
And clearly in a situation
where the sky is burning
as you have in the dinosaur example,
very few organisms we're
gonna be able to adapt
to those types of circumstances.
But you can also have fast change
that might not seem so
fast to us as human beings.
For example, this chart right over here
shows extinctions since 1500.
And I encourage you to pause this video
and make sure you're processing
what is going on here,
because that's a skill in and of itself,
but it's really interesting.
This tells us the cumulative percentage
of species driven extinct
over the last 500 years or so.
And so you can see
relative to the species
that were there in 1500,
if we follow let's say
the line for amphibians,
amphibians it looks like
someplace between 2% and 2 1/2%
of all species of amphibians
have gone extinct.
This is not saying 2% to 2 1/2%
of the amphibians have died.
This is saying the species of amphibians,
they don't exist anymore.
That variant of amphibian genotypes
don't exist in our world anymore.
And it's pretty bad for amphibians
but we can see it's pretty bad
for other types of animals as well.
And you might say,
well, this isn't so bad, 2% to 2 1/2%.
But once again,
these are entire species
that we will never see again
and what's also troubling
is how these curves are
just rocketing upwards.
And some of you all might be thinking,
isn't there always some
baseline level of extinction?
Maybe this isn't so much
worse than that baseline.
And what's interesting
about this graphic here is
it shows us the baseline.
This little gray square they're saying
that's the cumulative
percentage of species
based on background rate
of 0.1 to 2 extinctions
per million species per year.
And so you see the baseline
in this little gray
right down here.
If we didn't have unusual
amounts of extinction,
we would just be charting
roughly close to this line.
But you can see since 1500,
we have gone well above it
and we know why this is happening.
Their environments are
changing very, very quickly.
And who is the main culprit here
of changing the environment
very, very quickly?
Well, what group's population
has really expanded
over the last 500 years?
And you would of course say human beings.
And human beings, it's
not just where they live
and they're taking habitats away,
you can imagine this
environment is very different
than the environment of
what modern day Los Angeles
would have been say 500 years ago.
And it's not just where we live,
it's also the food we
need and we do need food.
But that takes up ecosystems environments
where other animals might have lived
and it could be a dramatic change
where they can't live anymore.
And so human land and
agricultural land use
is a major source of extinctions.
But on top of that,
we go into the sea and we
sometimes will over fish.
That can be a source of extinction.
Lack of diversity.
As more and more species
learn to live with humans
and maybe our lack of diversity,
we only have a few types of crops,
a few types of cattle that we grow.
There might be certain species
that live well with them
that are able to live off of them,
but they might not have as much variation
because the ecosystem is so not diverse
and so there's some change,
the species won't have the
variation necessarily to survive.
On top of that, you throw
in things like pollution,
global warming, invasive species,
and you can see why
these curves are going up
in a very, very, very troubling way.
And I will add,
this isn't just for us
to care about animals,
although that is a good motivation
for us to care about the species,
because once a species has gone,
you're never going to get it back again.
But in general,
the less diversity that
earth as a whole has,
it means that our ecosystems
are going to become
less and less robust to change.